so while there's been a lot more focus
on marketing electric vehicles in the
last couple of years it's actually
pretty old um using uh ads for marketing
electric vehicles during my research i
realized that they go back all the way
to the end of the 19th century when
brands like baker motor and hub gates
which aren't even companies around these
days were putting ads and magazines uh
promoting evs that you know at the time
are a lot different than the ones we
have now they can only go 50 to 60 miles
on a charge more recently you know back
in probably a decade or two ago they
started seeing them in tv ads for toyota
when the prius came out and then um you
know even a few years ago popping up the
super bowl ads
so i started noticing this shift in eb
marketing probably definitely early 2021
general motors had had a big splash at
ces last year with the campaign starting
malcolm gladwell and another rebrand
where they redid their logo for the
first time in a while and then super
bowl they had a ad with will ferrell and
a bunch of other celebrities as the year
went on i started just continuing to
notice this shift in marketing and how
these brands that
used to have maybe one eva vehicle at a
time now marketing things at the
corporate level
you know one of the analysts i talked to
last year who covers the auto industry
pointed out that a lot of these brands
the way he put it they're no longer just
going after the birkenstock wearing soy
latte sipping uh you know green angle
for a lot of these vehicles and they're
they're wanting to go after the luxury
buyers that are more interested in how
cool a car looks or how fancy it is that
it's just to help the environment you're
seeing brands that want to be a part of
pop culture they want to be a part of
celebrity conversations in order to
market these things not just to people
that want to save money or help the
environment that one but they want to
kind of tap into the cultural zeitgeist
with these big moments whether it's at
the super bowl or with big time movies
or whatever else so for example disney
uh partnered with general motors on a
campaign for the chevy volt
so you had um you know classic disney
characters like peter pan and dumbo
showing up in in one of those
commercials and spider-man uh actually
worked with hyundai on an ad as well
this year mercedes benz is working out
on a collaboration with avatar one of
the other notable moments last year was
at saturday night live back in may when
elon musk was posting obviously he's the
ceo of tesla and has a has a large fan
base that loves to follow whatever he
does and that night when he had his
guest appearance actually several other
auto brands had to do by ad string snl
to market their evs during the show
it was hard to get a total for 2021 in
terms of how much was spent on eb
marketing but a couple things i did find
was there's a research firm called media
radar that
estimated that ev's ev spending mostly
disappeared during in 2020 during the
height of the pandemic but
in 2021 at least from january to july
spending was at 33 million which was up
quite a bit from 19 which was you know
only at 20 million but that's still a
small drop in the bucket when you're
thinking about you know how much was
spent during the same period last year
from january to july with the overall
auto market was spending around three
billion dollars in advertising during
the first half of the year
one of the other things that i think
helped to accelerate the shift to evs
last year was uh the biden
administration's focus on sustainability
and preventing climate change
and
you saw a lot of the car brands kind of
reading the tea leaves and wanting to
get ahead of things whether it's
regulatory changes or just consumer
changes that people wanting to do their
part to protect the environment so you
know they're putting a lot more money
into making vehicles that people might
want to buy as a for environmental
reasons
you've got some auto brands that are
actually instead of just making entirely
new models that are electric powered
they're taking their gas powered
vehicles and making electric versions so
we've seen uh ford do that with this
mustang
and also the ford f-150 hyundai's been
doing that so that way if people don't
necessarily want to get an entirely new
car they can take the car they're
familiar with but just swap out the gas
for a charger
you know whether these will catch on is
it's kind of still hard to tell but it's
probably like a lot of things people
don't necessarily
want to take a bet on spending anywhere
between 20 30 40
50 000 in a car until they know it's
gonna fit within their life so i'm sure
as these things become more common
they're gonna see their neighbors and
their friends driving cars and i think
as they get more popular people are
going to realize that maybe it isn't the
biggest
issue to switch from a gas power vehicle
to an ev as they maybe previously
thought
you